Thanks for coming. This is going
to be about video games and uh,
axillary content associated with the
video game industry stuff that spins out,
you know, everybody has an
intellectual property product, right?
Video game and no one expects the Spanish
inquisition or that was the reference
to it in 1980s phones. Anybody
get that? Cause you know,
I'm riffing off of 1980s video
game culture a little bit.
That's why I have the ready player
one thing going on. So I don't,
that's not a spoiler alert.
Spoiler alert.
I don't want to ruin ready player one of
the great movie and the book. Any hope?
So yes. Uh, people have, uh,
intellectual properties, right?
They make them a video game and no one
expects all kinds of derivative works.
What kinds of things are
going to spin out of them?
Definition of what a derivative work is
is pretty fixed when it comes to things
like Harry Potter, right? If I
write fan fiction on Harry Potter,
that's a derivative work.
I'm using all the characters,
maybe spinning off the storyline, but if
I do a derivative work of a video game,
what does that mean?
Is it if I record myself playing a video
game right and may commentary and do
crazy tricks or whatever is that it's a
bit of work or is that transformative?
Which is it? Right. So a lot of
this has to do with that question.
A lot of the research that I've done has
to do with that question of transition
between well had had is something like
a platform like youtube afford that kind
of playing. By what I mean
by afford, I mean, uh,
that's from like HCI langue
language. You guys get it right. Uh,
that means well are the,
is going to let this happen or not?
They preventative and that
positive affordances or not.
And it's also a play on words.
Can you afford the intellectual property
liability that you might want if you
want to make your platform particularly
playful to let your users make your out
with intellectual property products
that maybe are not on, you know,
could be transformative,
could not be transformative but
mashup culture or you know, practices.
People scroll down a little bit with
the intellectual property product, uh,
me give you something entirely new,
entirely transformative.
And as a platform owner,
you capitalize that as a participant in
that you get to share in the profits,
hopefully. So how do you design
platforms that strike that balance?
That's the underlying
question, right? I don't know.
I started doing this work in 2009.
I lived a blessed existence.
I get to play video games and, and call
that and just have so much fun. Right?
And that's my research and
I get to play video games.
I get to hang out with video gamers.
I get to hang out with communities that
love playing games and ask them how it
is they take something that they love so
much and transition it into a business,
a business product,
or
sent it out there to the world.
What compels them to do that?
Culture is important, right? If
you're going to design something,
I would say you need a
cultural anthropologist,
especially if you have it really
committed community for the,
for the product that you hope to host,
let's say on your platform, right?
You need to find out what,
what matters to them the most.
So that's what motivates me.
Uh,
the intellectual property question is
important to me. I mean, I've written,
I've written a book on it. I've been
called the copyright and our, uh, yes,
because I have a really limited,
I'm not a big fan of
the US copyright system,
so if you want to read my book,
you can get it for free from the MIT
press because I magically negotiated a
creative Commons license for it
and people start trying, if you,
about how I manage that.
So it's available, you can
download it for free. Okay.
So here's what I got.
Is this look familiar to anybody,
right? This is twitch
plays Pokemon. Uh, and
twitch isn't a particular,
back when I started this
project in [inaudible] in 2009,
video game commentary was
still in its infancy. Yeah.
Uh,
maybe the fo the
directors that the party that
I guess directors who were, um,
starting out the channels have you had a
hundred a hundred subscribers a hundred
times this. All right. Um,
but I thought it's going
to become something I,
and I wondered why Youtube has really
done a great job in making it possible for
a platform to be just super plastic.
In other words,
have the ability to accommodate all kinds
of different content in a modular way
so that users can adaptively
put their content opt in,
whatever way that they can identify with.
Then I,
then after some time of doing that,
Justin TV,
I remember Justin TV, the first version
of twitch. All right. So then twitch, um,
was even more plastic I think. But that's
not to say that youtube isn't great,
it's just that, okay, this
is a different set of, uh,
and the reason why is it
their intellectual property
or their terms of service
requirements for a little less stringent.
So in this case,
twitch plays Pokemon
in case you don't know,
and I get to play a little bit
of a video, um, is someone,
obviously the channel owner hacked away
at the interface so that check a man's
would end up being play commands,
right?
So anybody who was watching the livestream
cause instant chat, check a man's man,
and you ended up playing Pokemon even
though you technically should be the
audience watching the live stream. Right?
But not, you're a good player. So are,
are you ready to be a player
as an audience? That's great.
I was sitting on a at Virginia Tech and
a panel with the associate registrar of
Copyrights, right? The, the,
the second in command copyright
officer in United States.
And I raised this question is who do
we blame? Uh, who, who's liable for it?
The NCA claim digital copyright.
It's funny because obviously there was
some circumvention right? Some patent,
log out, whacked up a little bit, and
we could not come to that conclusion.
And not that, not that
twitch cared, not right.
Maybe Nintendo cared. Nintendo tends
to care more than other companies,
but not the twitch cared.
And who would you hold Bible and he
was so the plasticity of the platform,
and I want you to guys if you can
remember that word plasticity, uh,
allowed for modular putting together
like what you would consider disparate
platforms of video game platform
and interface on [inaudible].
I want a webpage,
a platform and a chat commands it a lot
of this modularity to come together to
this novel product and it
kept going. Right. All right,
so as a designer I would think,
I mean I used to teach for product
and design innovation at Rensselaer
polytechnic and modularity,
the ability to have a,
have enough structure
to have fixed elements,
but enough plasticity
to have the user design.
It's his or her ultimate imagined
use. That's magic. Right?
That's great. And that's, I didn't
have to know that the system,
the screen infinity anyway, so that's
how I started thinking about platforms.
Generally.
How do you design them in video game
culture was particularly well suited to
study it because they're always playing.
They're always hacking away either at
the game rules, right? How to cheat,
how to work arounds, uh, or
also how to show their content.
So let me just, I'm going to place in
the background. Do not be distracted.
All right? If you want, it
can be a script. I don't
know. There's no sound. Okay.
You're going to be distracted on,
I'll talk to you. Anyway. So in 2009,
I started following the
call of duty community
called Duke community.
It started with my wife for two.
I needed to play better because
I suck. And um, I thought, well,
maybe youtube has it,
how to write.
And it turns out it was entertaining
beyond its use of value. In other words,
I could learn some things from the
people that was watching. By the way,
this is me. Um, I can learn things
from the people I was watching,
but I also found an
incredibly entertaining,
it was entertaining for so many reasons
that the commentary that the way they
were talking about the
game play was great. Uh,
the tips and tricks were great and
maybe they weren't terrible. Yes,
I know it's modern warfare.
I know this is the black ops and I know
there's a lot of problems with game
culture generally, so I'm focusing
on the, on the positive. So, um,
so there was a lot of learning
to be done anyway. Uh,
this guy isn't bad, Huh? It's not
bad for a college professor. Um,
so anyway,
what I learned was that gamers have
put together a whole bunch of different
types of technologies to make
themselves better. That's great.
But also that they had created
entertainment of doing it
by doing it because the
platform had afforded it and the platform
that [inaudible] three things that are
really important, right? It gave them a
sense of ownership. So in other words,
what people could do by modifying
the game from a play experience to a
viewership product.
Give them a sense of ownership.
That's what Henry Jenkins not at USC
is called a moral economy, right?
So if your platform can afford a little
bit of moral of the economy from your
audience, that's a win because
now they're invested, right?
That requires people to
give away, give, give up.
The idea that any media product is,
is a done product.
Who here has written anything or design
something and you sort of set it out in
the world, right? And then you think, gee,
that's it. I will struggle.
Then I sweat. And that was,
but then what would you do if someone
comes along and Margit modifies it in some
way changes,
it creates friction out of it.
The idea is that the platform
should have an element of, um,
welcoming things that are modifications
of media, existing media products,
which would be a derivative work.
Right? But that gives people ownership.
That's great.
The other thing is belonging.
The sense of belonging is anybody
here know the term? Brony. Okay.
Could you, okay. Should
I clarify that for folks?
A brony is typically a young man between
the ages of 18 or even younger and
however, who has an affinity?
A fanish affinity fans.
They're fans of my little pony.
My little pony is a TV series from
the 1980s features are little pony.
They're kind of cute. Any who, um,
this fan group would have been an isolated
fan group if it hadn't been for the
web. Right? Once they get on the
web and started talking about it,
they created an emergent culture.
Now you can go to a comic con, right?
Does anybody here at bent to comicon?
I'm sure many people have been to
comic con. If you go to Comicon,
you'll see people playing,
doing cosplay on a my little pony.
The point of this is that the platform of,
let's say the Internet,
if we're going to talk in a big terms,
created a space for culture to
exist to happen to exist outside of,
let's say your own small group of
people or even just yourself, right?
Culturally requires more than one video.
Game. Culture is the same way, right? It,
especially around this particular genre
of video game commentary that if it
wasn't for the fact that a
platform afforded communication
with others about the
game and things that maybe
were experienced in the game,
then that sense of cultural belonging is
something that's bigger than yourself.
It would have been lost.
You would have maybe had friends
to play with maybe land parties,
but otherwise there wouldn't be
anything bigger or that grows.
So that's great for the platform.
And then freedom of movement,
freedom of movement means the idea
that the platform isn't locked up,
that the feature set interfaces with other
feature sets that may not necessarily
be owned by your platform. Right. Okay.
So I'm going to quickly bring
myself up to date because you know,
I talk and then my notes,
we'll recycle it refocused me.
All right, so these are the three
sort of the, the magic recipe, right?
The triumvirate. And let's
see, here we go. He covered it.
All of these. And then are we good at
this guy? Uh, the ghost in the shell.
If you're going to have a platform,
right?
That is going to afford a level of
plasticity of a level of user or power.
You're going to have to be prepared
for indeterminacy and surprises, right?
Things are gonna happen in,
in a system that is already
chaotic because there are
so many moving parts that
are going to be wholly unexpected
game designers notice, right?
They call it emergence emergence in AI
but also emergency and player, uh, um,
behavior. But also you can think of
it as emergency and user behavior.
And I think the youtube gaming
community show that particularly well,
right? Things happen on
the youtube game community.
I think we're entirely unexpected.
The twitch thing is the twitch plays.
Pokemon is great,
but also the fact that there is such
a thing as a video game commentary.
And this is before youtube gaming,
by the way.
So all my references are historical.
Yes, Youtube gaming now exists,
but it wouldn't have existed if it
hadn't first existed as youtube video
commentary for years before that.
Right? This starts in 28, 2008,
2009 and youtube came, he didn't
come out until 2015. Right?
So it took a whole year as a response
to this level of user activity, right?
And as a responsible for the competition,
twitch was really ready to,
to dole out on that particular field,
right?
So you gotta be ready for surprises
and video game commentary.
Communities provided the proof of that,
that they were going to do
interesting and new things. And okay,
so you want to have a platform that gives
you some plasticity, some user control,
belonging, a sense of belonging,
moot freedom of movement.
Um, and let me go back to
that one and ownership, right?
But then you have to balance it because,
well, you are a corporation, so,
all right? Uh, it has to be
balanced with some things. Uh,
you have to have the freedom
to create, play, right?
To be able to play in the
platform at the same time.
That has to be balanced with three things,
overly grabby copyright regimes.
Obviously that's the death
star with a big C. Right?
And all your creativity are belong to us.
Does anybody know that particular
reference to video game culture? Right?
Uh,
there's a,
there's a great video game
from the 80s that it was,
it was dubbed over with,
with dicey English and it's an,
all your base are belong to us.
It's awesome. So it'd become,
it's become a thing in video.
So now every time we talk about something
ridiculous, like I'm going to get you,
we say all your base are belong us.
So that's why I have it on there.
All your co it creativity or belong to us.
So you don't want to be this deathstar
you don't want to be the platform, right?
That says all your creativity are
belong to us. You do not. Right.
Especially with with w when the culture
is one of sharing and the culture is one
of participation with the culture
is one of performance, right? Um,
that is going to be a hard sell.
Okay.
So there is overly grabby copyright
regimes purposefully designed in
compatibility between platforms. You
don't want to close off your platforms.
The reason that youtube system worked
was because it was pretty open.
Who here can a,
has ever seen the CBS logo show up in
the NBC and an NBC program broadcast
anywhere, anytime ever in
mass media. Never. Never.
Right. Yeah, but you're on youtube.
They have a Twitter logo. You
guys are mixing your copy,
you guys are mixing your,
your trademarks and you don't care
because your platform around the youtube
platform is open to others.
That is a win. If you,
if I were to use economics,
I would say that's a great example
of the Nash Equilibrium, right?
Of maximizing overall wealth by loosening,
by making decisions about choices.
Right?
That that account for at the end,
everybody wins state like a zero sum game.
Right? All right. So
it has to be a certain acceptance
of chaos, right? Um, that
users are,
aren't really,
users are going to do what ads and a
particular brand of use or a particular
type of participatory user is going
to do it much more so than others.
But these might be the users that you
want to foster an afford cause they are
the most creative.
They're going to,
they're inventing things on the fly
and they wish they could do it. Right.
Uh, so let me give you the perspective
from a video gamer. Someone like myself,
right? Yes, I am. I, that's
the other thing. You can't
really talk about a medium,
right? Unless you really, I
don't know, Taco, unless you
submerge yourself in it. Um,
you know, it's really important
to just really be veracious,
right? About a medium that you love
and, you know, talk about. Um, okay.
So here it goes.
This is the view of the
youtube platform from, uh,
a Gamer's perspective circa 2009.
We'll start with what did video gamers
who are going to put stuff online?
Sage was the profit motive of Youtube.
This is it.
This,
it's basically they didn't care to that
as far as they're concerned is the gnome
plan for profit, right? Uh,
they knew, you'd said was,
could a collecting everything.
That's the metaphor. The underpants
just collect anything that's visual.
The profit motive or the profits
system was unknown to them,
or they didn't care at the beginning.
Uh,
and all they really cared about was
playing and sharing their passion.
That was it.
That who here knows about
creative communities is
anybody who participated in a
creative community,
creative communities tend to not care
about the profit motive too much,
especially in the stages when we were
in the stage and when they're putting up
there their rough drafts, right?
It's important for them to share,
but the profit motive is really not
always in their scheme of thinking.
And this is why I have,
this isn't one of my favorite
elements of south park or moments in south
park when they presented the plan for
profit, which is basically the
beginning. This is how they saw it.
But of course that changed right?
When partnerships rolled in and when
you do partnerships rolled in with
machinima partnerships.
So showing up,
then that changed and the
profit motive became very real.
Then their mindset changes.
But this is the beginning.
This is the other thing
that's really important.
Who can recognize this particular
image? Anybody? Yeah, there we go.
That is working. I think I've stitched,
watched it again the other day. Uh,
this is one of the first true
representations of video game culture.
And this is 19, what, 84, 85.
So what Youtube Youtube commentators
did was recreate this moment.
They recreated this moment. I know
I'm going to date myself. Okay.
And the 80s after I got out of school,
I would gather my quarters from my,
the pittance of my paper route
and I would head over to the,
to Jimmy smoke shop in new Britain,
Connecticut. It's a post industrial town,
not a lot of money to go around
and were just working class kids.
And we had quarters and
we didn't have Atari.
So we would go to the
arcade and play video games,
things like a lag or a pac man or whatever
and meet other people and talk about
the games and learn how,
how to better play the game and
develop culture in situ on site. Right.
Um, maybe meet some cool older
kids who were much better at it.
We would even cheer and we would
tribalized right. Ah, you're,
have you like Bob's way of
playing Pac man? He's a punk. Uh,
all these things were real,
but in flesh and bomb,
the culture existed in flesh and Bonk.
Right.
And we got to talk shit to each other.
We got to call each other names,
um, calling each other's moms
names, whatever it was, right.
Instead of going to play basketball,
maybe cause we used to do that.
You have them anyway.
Play basketball on the city.
If you play basketball in inner city,
talking smack is like a skill. Okay.
So if you, if you don't
talk smack, you saw it,
just you or even worse, you know. Uh,
so you had the talk yet talk smack.
That was how it was.
And if you could read,
if I wish I could,
I wish there were a cam quarters back
then or cell phones that I could record it
because I, it, it existed.
Youtube created that again,
not in the same way. It wasn't flushing
born. It wasn't at the same time. It was,
you know, um, across time zones and in,
but you got to talk a lot of crap.
You got to cheer for your friends,
got to do all these things. Uh,
and you got to meet New People.
So Youtube when we created this,
I don't know if they did it inadvertently
or whether the gamers who were putting
the stuff up there knew it,
this is what they were doing.
Or maybe it's just the
way the medium works.
But this is one of the reasons
why it also works, right?
Because whatever it is
about video game culture,
this kind of competitive play and come
ridership and smack talky existed before
just not online. It
exists. So just reproduced.
So that's another thing that it afforded
that the platform afforded, right?
Importing external cultures, that's
really important. Uh, uh, practices.
So does anybody recognize
any of this era plate?
So I'm think talking about one particular
game because it was sort of the most
popular game of the time, uh, on the
Xbox and playstation platforms, right?
Modern warfare series. Okay.
Y'all play video games,
I'm assuming. And some gay video
games just have elements of suck,
right?
They might be great in some respects,
but there are other elements
that just stank and you,
you know it when you're
playing it and you think, God,
I wish I could just tell the designers
how has it just socks or, um,
talk to somebody about how much,
so this is a little poster of the most
hated elements of modern warfare two and
I'm going to focus on this one,
boosting a, if you've played this game,
I'll give you the game
mechanic real quickly. Uh,
let's say you're in competitive
play and someone, you know, you get,
you get knocked out on the competition,
respond back in,
but there's a thing you can attack in
certain places. You, you break the stick,
you put it down and you will respond
exactly where that insert was located.
Great. You get, you
get, you get to respond.
But people started doing that so they
can get kill streaks so he can get an
award so that you would get your buddy
to show up in there and online play and
you'd sit or cabin a corner,
you know,
sneaky in this crack this thing.
And then you shoot each other in the
head a couple of times and just keep
spawning.
There's a ridiculous right.
And it was game breaking because you
sitting there playing the game, you're,
you're super competitive,
you're doing it and then you hear
and you hear it in the sand because you
have your headset to cause your bass
player. Right? Cause you,
you know what you're doing,
you have your surrounds it and you
thinking who the hell is cheating?
So you started trolling going on the map.
You few forget the objective of the
game because you know someone's in some
corner of shooting,
you know cheating.
So you go around and you're looking
around and you find the realize they're
cheating and all don't
she where she could test.
So you get to go in the
lobby and talk about it,
but not no more talking about it no more.
Let's say you get until,
Oh let me make sure this is science cause
this guy gets pretty serious about it.
Is he a boy? It's slow. Oh there it is.
So this kind of made a series of
videos on tracking these cheaters.
And you know, making their lives
difficult, uh, for cheating. So he,
but he was pretty exciting. He did it
pretty interesting Joe about it. Um,
I want to race him just
a little bit kiss maybe.
Uh,
and he's a fan of hard rock.
So chat looking who hey on that.
So he would find his chairs
and, and little corners of
that map and put and put,
put the,
put the hurting on him and really creative
ways like throwing sand tax at, um,
and you, you understand, you share
the ovary, that's Duke Nukem.
So not only was she used
a number of interaction,
not only what he, this is awesome.
And he was on Justin TV by the way.
So he was on the first live streamers. I'm
just in TV circa 2009. Um, sorry. Yeah.
So his thing was,
his said became entertained.
So this moment that you had in
video game culture, right, and the,
and you're playing at home or playing
with friends of hating on the game became
entertainment for you. Right.
Who here has ever had some,
who here has gone to the dentist and
felt, you know, and had a terribly nickel,
particularly painful,
then that's just experience and then
gone online and watched other people have
it and laughed hysterically. And I don't
know, maybe you're crazy like that,
but I haven't. But this, that's the idea.
It took something that was a user
experience, right? In video games,
I was objectionable.
I, someone's cheating.
People get angry and made entertainment.
It made the kind of TV
journalist called people, uh, uh,
characters you love to hate.
Right?
So that was afforded by the platform
and the creativity of the user.
But think of what,
how many intellectual property products
went into that particular cut. There's,
there's,
uh,
some rock music and I think she used
to use Metallica until the copyright
strikes started coming in
Berlin town, right? Uh, he's
using Duke Nukem voiceovers,
you know, like a tasty, right?
Things like that. And that comes,
that's an intellectual property product.
And I don't know if youtube has an Algo
to be recognize those kinds of, uh,
sound inputs, but that's still
going. So I don't think so. Um,
so these are a number of Loosey Goosey
applications of transformative works,
right? Um, to make that happen.
Now I've been talking about features that
keep cobbled together and media can be
a cobbled together in a platform that
allows all this to happen, right?
But it's not just one platform
is a number of platforms.
Think of it as a brick collage. That
was pretty fancy word for a gaming guy.
So it, it just means like
a, a hodgepodge, right?
You put it all together to make this one.
So think of the experience of this
sort of creating a 14 play as a,
a collage of features. It's, it's bigger
than the one than the one platform.
If the plastic, here's Twitter, right?
I mean, come on. How many, you know,
youtube has his Twitter, you can set
a little Twitter icon there somewhere.
Um,
how often has this happened that
a platform is just entirely of,
any media is open to other inputs
from other media that's really unique.
That is not something that happens often.
And there might be some cases,
but I think in mass media, and I
always, when I say it's unique,
I say it's unique and meet it
mass me to do not have this uh,
traditional mass media, digital media
because of the network environment.
Do have it. So let me scroll here.
So my notes, I'm staying on track.
Yes I am. Okay, good. All right.
This allowed for a certain
kind of narrative to evolve
when you hear a story or when you read
a story, right? It's to book, right?
Or it's the, it's the
podcast. So it's the radio.
What if the story stopped at the book?
I said follow,
follow the rest of the story on Twitter.
I follow the [inaudible] study on Youtube.
So that is the idea.
I'm trying to get at that.
The narratives,
the stories that they were told
through this video language,
we're not just confined to the
one they were across platforms.
So the plasticity is not just
about all of the features sets,
it's about the ways in
which the one mass that's,
we'll call it the central platform.
Youtube allowed the other one's in and
out and so allowed users to flow through
right there.
My favorite example is the Twitter beef.
I love Twitter beefs. They're
so fun. So these commentators,
which each Twitter beef, they start
hating on each other on Twitter, right?
Like in high school or middle school
you hated on each other and the English
class and then you went outside
and settle your differences.
Or maybe you challenge each other to a
dual, I don't know, whatever it was this,
they would start Twitter be so here on
Twitter and then the story would continue
somewhere in the channel where they would
have themselves some, some, some heat,
go back and forth and then they would
go somewhere else. Then it would go to,
on the comments section is there,
this was staged in a lot of cases.
They just had called each other up. We
were actually good friends and they say,
why don't we,
you know,
our viewers of viewership is a little
down or why don't we stage some drama?
And it would,
but it had flow throughout.
So let's say you're at school
and you're wondering, well,
how much hate Barb is
giving the Jan today?
So you go on Twitter and various sort
of firing up your, your video, right?
A youtube APP. You just kind of go on
Twitter and see where the heat is at.
He out,
unfortunately I'm using here,
doesn't like sometimes it
was collaboration and some
sort of like projects that
they were working on. So these things
are, but it wouldn't be possible.
This sort of multimodal narrative about,
uh, of one media product when you parcel,
unless there was this plasticity
civilly link things together. Um,
so users are like kittens,
um,
especially when they're given a
significant amount of freedom.
They will create things,
they will mess things up.
Sometimes they will import
things that you didn't expect,
but there will also be super
cute, uh, like kittens. No,
maybe not sort of super cute,
but they will also put together things
that you did not expect they will create
for you. All right. Um,
my summary of this and the narratives
that evolve will be multimodal.
Uh,
it's a real interesting way to look at it.
And in terms of discrete infinity,
that all these different elements to
the platforms that you put together,
the, does anybody here, does everybody
know the term, the screen infinity?
Maybe this great infinity is the idea
that you have limited modules but infinite
possibilities, right? Limited
components, infant outputs.
It's a term from linguistics to explain
why limited number of phenoms or letters
can produce infinite number of words,
right?
Or it's also in AI and
limited number of circuitry.
Yours things crews on indeterminate
number of outputs. All right?
So
if you can create a modular
platform that affords playfulness,
not only with its feature set,
but also with the way the content
is mashed up and other platforms,
you will have discrete infinity,
you will have a near infinite
resource for creativity.
That's my hypothesis. That's
my findings. I think I,
things happen in these platforms that
I could never have expected and I don't
think getting machine could ever
have computed the possibilities.
So I love this image.
This image is my metaphor
for well-designed platform.
There are rules to this game that
these kids are playing, right?
But there are nearly invisible to them.
And the ball is the platform and they are
in conversation with that platform and
that platform is in conversation with
them. It is adapting to them, right?
They all kick it, right? They'll make
it go in one direction or another,
but they're an effect.
The game that they're playing
with it revolves around
the nearly invisible rules,
which they all know,
right?
Which they function within
and the physics of the ball,
but also the magic that happens when
you're playing quickly and a ball goes
somewhere on direct, uh, unexpected.
It's just the metaphor. All right,
so what are the takeaways?
Let's say,
what did we learn and how is it possible
you're the audience participation side
of it also has a lot to do
with who is contributing.
I cannot emphasize this enough,
these users,
we're not thinking about copyright
strikes. They could not care less, right?
They could not care less.
It was the latter. It only
was part of their imaginary.
When they got a copyright
strike, channel's got shut
down. When music was pulled,
for whatever reason,
one of my videos was yanked when
on my channel because I decided,
I decided to use, it's beginning to
look a lot like Christmas. Right?
And it lasted 24 hours before I got
yanked on my channel because, well,
there's a copyright strike on it.
So,
but I care because all I know I have
to care about copyright. But these,
these folks could do not.
And that's the other thing that there
is some audiences, just our in state,
maybe in life, right? 18 to 12, 12 to
18 year olds that just don't care. Um,
and sometimes that's the
best place that there's a,
there's a great book called the
art of not giving a shit. Um,
and there's an element
to that in creativity and
gamers have that humans have
that in the way hackers do, in the
positive way. Hackers that hacker,
the majority of science, and
there's hackers, you know,
curious folks who are tinkerers
who like to play with things.
If you give those a culture
days playful with things,
the ability to play with them, they
will create things for you, right?
So these are my findings. Obviously
the intellectual property, uh,
narrative and the profit motive kicks
in some companies that are more than
others,
but ultimately I think the findings are
all that a belonging sense of belonging,
a sense of ownership and freedom
of movement are the key elements.
These things will limit them,
but the corporate culture is
actually really important. All right?
So things like copyright,
things like contractual agreements with
your users from third party owners,
these things will limit or create a
balance in the balance and the platform
designer has to design
that balance into it. But
the corporate culture has a lot to do
with it actually hacker culture as well.
Um,
and of all this,
of all the communities that I've studied
in my lifetime, online video game,
a video game,
players are a lot like hackers,
um,
and the corporate culture.
Does anybody here ever modded a
video game? So I was right. So
video game industry has been really
open to letting its trade secrets and
intellectual properties out of the door,
right?
That's hacker culture in
its, in its essence, right?
Here's the source code hack away
at it lets you, I remember I hated,
I didn't hate him,
I love the physics and quake three,
but I kind of wanted to run
next to a missile sometimes. So,
and I went in there and I hacked away at
it and I slowed the missile speed down.
So then I would just sit there and run
next to a missile and they do crazy
things because it was
fun to do it and people,
and I put that modern mine
and people downloaded the mod.
So the point is that
of all the industries,
the media and the creative industries,
video game sense, it'd be a little less,
a little more open to letting their
platforms be converted a little bit,
the modified, right. So that new
creative things can happen. Uh,
so corporate culture is important.
I would imagine.
My dream platform for media
sharing is one that is modular,
wondering which a user
can pick and choose.
The kinds of presentations
that the kinds of formats, um,
that he or she wants to present and how
they want to present them. And each page,
each user page is you unique youtube
experience. It's still youtube,
but it's Jane, Jane's Youtube. All right?
So these are the three Cs of success,
right?
And it was these three seniors
probably existed already.
And if you've worked for you to be, you
probably know that they were doing this,
but it wasn't obvious to,
to the viewership.
But after following this community
for long enough, it is, to me,
there's subscribers are the common,
the common currency,
um, and that you have to have ways
of catching them or recruiting them,
growing your audience. And that can be
done in a number of ways. The first is,
of course, great content. Yes, people will
show up, but also you would like to show,
uh, incentivize them to come.
So maybe giveaways. All right.
Uh, so I, the first time, I think the
first time any user generated content,
um,
for video games which showed up on the,
on the homepage,
the splash page or youtube
was when one gamer x jaws is,
I had to do a giveaway and if
you rate comment as described,
he would put your name. He was giving
away x boxes, I mean big giveaway.
And I just like, oh, I'll give you
some like, uh, I'll give you candy. No,
like big things.
And he started getting millions of views.
His subscriber base tripled.
So he had a great catching strategy.
He got a lot of hate for right
from the rest of the community.
Cause it's supposed to be a meritocracy,
but there's other ways of catching it.
You making,
uh,
entertain content and to entertaining
content requires maybe staging a beef or
some drama and people show up and
that catches them cashing them.
That means you have to keep them right.
And so that's engagement
through other platforms. Again,
because the platform afforded it,
they were able to put the little
Twitter out and tell them, hey,
I'm going to be on or have a hosted
lobby. And lastly, caching him.
And that is the partnership programs.
Initially there were no partnership
programs initially. You know,
you have to have certain number of
viewership. Once word got around,
the profit motor really kicked
in for them. Um, but again,
the platform afforded it.
So what's the take them ultimately
concluding you fast questions if you have
them is jazz fans. This is, uh,
uh, a picture of the recording of
a miles Davis kind of blue, right?
Some jazz fans considered this proof
of the existence of God. All right. Uh,
because, uh, Ge, uh, David's
basically gave his, uh, his, uh,
content,
key signatures and tempo.
And then they went at it and
they created a tonal jazz and,
and a number of settings.
Uh, creativity flow.
That's because the platform, the
rules of the platform, the structure,
we're fixed in tempo key,
right?
But everything else was up to the players.
And that if you,
if I think if platform designers start
to see their users as players and afford
play and just give basic directions,
what will come out at the end
will be the next miles Davis,
the next Michelangelo,
the next, um, whomever,
right? Genius. If you have enough,
if you will be happy or at least designers
will be happy that they built the
tools,
they gave them,
the canvases that they were able
to use to become those geniuses.
Um, so that's the take home message is
the balance between structure and play.
And we've seen users as playful agents,
not as folks that you need to shut today.
You need to structure
their behavior too much.
And the video game commentary community
and the beginning historically really
showed that twitch is a
lot of ways doing crazy,
not crazy things. I would say they're
structures are far looser. I see.
I've seen things on twitch.
I mean I've been having,
looking at the web for 20 years, um,
that made my jaw drop. I'm like, wow.
And they, they've monetized it. Um,
so the content can be loosey Goosey.
Sometimes it's,
it's problematic.
But those that's sort of the price.
You sometimes pay a more,
more,
you have to curate a little
bit more effectively.
And when you're going to let go,
may I create a little bit more
chaos that your users do? What apps?
That's the take home message.
That's how a platform affords play and um,
balances between the structure and the,
uh,
the ghost in the shell.
Any questions,
comments?
Yeah,
we would talk about your experience or
comment on kind of like how you think,
like things in the flesh now are kind
of like real life game play and kind of
ties in with all these
concepts you're talking about.
Yeah, I think, you know, one of the,
one of the mistakes I think a lot of
internet scholars do a is thing that,
you know, the culture is self contained,
right? But a lot of live action role play,
right?
So in those cases you are taking ganging
scenarios and putting them elsewhere,
right?
And live action and carrying them out.
And sometimes a game mechanics
are flawed in the game.
We've, you know, we've had, at least
the group I did it with was, uh,
was a, uh, failed failed feature.
Larb so it would be something
like a, um, ridiculous, like,
uh, the, in modern warfare two, it
was a second chance where, you know,
the guy sitting there like,
you shot him a thousand times,
but he's still kinda can get at you
and that's everybody considered a fail.
So one person got a ticket that was like,
you get to be that guy that ruins it
for everybody and nobody knew, right?
So it affects, you know, it, it,
it created this and it reinforced
the meaning that we had in the game.
Right?
Or sometimes we would do something in
Larb that we would then carry into the
game, right? There would
be one guy who'd be, um,
uh, you know, instead of, instead of, uh,
instead of it being as a team death match,
one guy would activate a grenade
instead of running around,
you know, and they're going
to blow up on you soon, right?
So he was the guy you had to find. Uh,
but that's something we had done in labs.
So, if that's what you mean. Yeah.
So there is this fluency between external
cultures and internal culture in the
game and the fact that we could
do it outside and bring it into,
let's say lobby recorded and then put
it on and became a genre onto itself.
Right?
So there were some lobbies you would
walk in and they weren't actually playing
the objective of the game.
They were playing an objective
they had devised somewhere else.
So you went into search and destroy
and it wasn't searching to start with
something else.
Um,
you went into team death match to replace
something else and that was the two.
So creativity, right. Did designers
never met the game to be that,
but someone, some group
in Lockton are that, um,
or they reinforce some sort of
notion of what the game should be?
So I think that's what
you mean. Yes. Yeah.
These are the conversations
between the external and internal.
The flushing bond on the digital.
I really important.
And if the platform allows for that
and the fandom allows for that,
then you have an opening door
for creative spaces. Yeah.
Yeah. Slab action, write
plays create really fun.
Yeah. I mean, I guess in general,
like I'm very curious about
like how things manifest
in like in real life or how
like what can be done in real
life that can or cannot read,
but we replicate it like on a digital
platform. So what would that be like Lara?
Absorb like args um, like
immersive theater, you know,
like what are the applications
of it and like, you know,
if you're thinking about the form of
theater itself is something that may
arguably be like somewhat fizzling out,
right?
Like what does it look like when you
inject these new ideas and do it right?
I think audience participation. So
for example, if, um, video game,
right? When when I, when we were in,
in the arcades and we were
participating in the game play,
if someone were to tell you,
would you ever really watch someone
on TV or on play a video game,
people are going to
know. But actually, yeah,
people were doing it for a long time for
watching other people play games for a
long time. Right. Uh, so the idea is find,
find media engagement exercises if
people do together in which others,
others take joy in watching
others do. Right? We all watch,
we all love watching other people
fail at sports height way. It's just,
it's comedy, right? We watched
and we watched and just epic
fail, epically fail. Uh,
we can't play the sport. We are
probably worse than they are. Uh,
they're not as good,
but we like watching that.
So those are the things that I think
people pour into the, let's say,
a video experience when it's
a flesh and bone experience,
when there is an element of
enjoyment and viewership on another.
So theater, right? Um,
I can't think of any other
than sort of sports fails. Uh,
or,
yeah,
sports shows me the first thing that
comes to mind where people like,
like to watch other folks sort of fumble
on themselves. Trip triple level. Uh,
and if that's what you mean
in terms of performances,
I think that's as close as I can get.
But in video games,
um,
children playing with the,
we has anyone seen a small child who
does not yet have full control of their
motor skills play with a Weise thick,
they beat each other with it.
It's hilarious. I wish that
was on youtube, right? Uh,
I know children but things like
that where it was a family moment.
It was hilarious.
A little Bobby just whacked Jimmy over
the head with that damn stick. And you,
you're lucky you have that little
rubber thing on it. But it's,
it's these elements of like that video
game culture that only happens in video
because the kids get fired up about it.
But there might be other elements in and
participatory culture in theater or in
uh, music, right. Music
fails are great as well.
I know fails and focusing on fails,
but they tend to be funny. And I got,
I got beaten in the face one time
with a baseball. Everybody laughed,
including myself, you know, it's
just like, okay, just got beat.
So fails tend to be kind of funny.
It's slapstick.
Any questions? Comments? Yes.
So you talked about a video
game community as well. Um,
so there's communities on Reddit,
there's communities on twitch,
streamer communities.
Do you have any insights on what
makes a community successful? Okay,
yes. Um, there has to be
a common language, right? [inaudible] and
what I mean by language, some symbolic,
right?
So everybody comes to it with an already
existing experience and they discover
that they all share that particular
symbolic experience and then they start to
circulate it.
If it's a particularly robust experience,
then that congeals a community
really quickly. Like for example,
the Brownie example, they started on
Reddit, right? Everybody had the general,
these, every member of that community
had the general experience of loving that
particular product and they didn't have
any place to present that until reddit
and others affirmed it
and it was so strong.
That connection there that can
do it almost instantaneously,
that community came together.
Uh,
so there has to be something
that ties in together,
some sort of common symbology.
Right? And that's strength.
Then there's also the dynamics.
Um,
there is sometimes you know,
roles emerging communities and at that
point you have the best communities are
usually communities are tend to be
horizontal, they tend to congeal,
the leadership is sparse.
So whenever someone starts to be a leader,
too much of a leader, it tends to not
work out. That tends to sort of, you know,
then people tribalized eco against each
others. There's beef, there's anger.
So horizontal communities tend to be
a pretty effective common symbology,
strong symbology. Um,
and the last of their,
I think it keeps communities
together is persistent.
So rest of the three big social proof,
a reciprocity and
consistency tend to be re.
So if they were start gifting in
the economy, that's a big deal.
Uninvited gifts are a huge deal.
Who here has been ever been
given an uninvited gift?
How compelled where you, you
wanted to give back? Right.
That is a very strong
social norm across cultural.
It doesn't matter if someone gives you
something you immediately want to give.
So that sort of a community in which
people are spontaneously gifting is really
tied together. Reciprocity, that's
important, right? Social proof.
If one particular element of the community
is affirmed by others that makes that
particular element, um,
our grounding element.
So everybody wears red on Thursdays
and everybody was more than few,
then it becomes a thing that people
do. Right. So, and then consistency,
a persistence of those things over time.
That just means people have to practice
it over and over again and sticking to
what they say.
I said I was going to do that.
These reciprocity is probably
the strongest, you know,
in a situation like that
information is a gift.
So if you're in a community and you share
information that wasn't as useful for
the community,
Ooh,
reciprocity immediately kicks in. So
those are the things. Thank you. Yep.
What else? All right. All right.
I have a question. Oh, go ahead.
I'm not sure if you're familiar
with the video game split tune. Uh,
it's been a while, but
yeah, with that one,
there's some game modes that are actually
closed off at specific points in time
and open up during certain periods
of time where certain days. Um,
and I always find that fascinating
because it's like the game itself is
restricting you from playing the game,
but it seems to work really well
in terms of players get, uh,
during specific days and that there's
always someone to play against.
And I think maybe some of that design
has actually been impacted by east sports
culture because I think Splatoon is
often featured is one of Nintendo's key
sports titles right now.
So I was wondering how east sports
culture has influenced the design of video
games over time and if there's any trends
in design that have resulted from that.
Yes.
Video Games since the e sports
and see Mlg crew hit, hit, hit,
hit, hit the airwaves, right? Uh,
they ha the designers will tap them for
ideas in terms of the kinds of play,
the kinds of tech they might
want to use. Um, that has been,
that's a mixed bag of success
and not as a player, right. As a,
because East sports players require,
require fast twitch reflects,
um, a particular type of competitive, um,
tech technological interface that
a regular player may not. Right.
Or,
and so our user may not an that casual
user or a person or a very committed fan.
I mean I find that particularly
use phone. Right. Um, I know, um,
I remember commentary once where they
were asking the designers were asking some
MLG players what they thought would be
great for call of duty and the community
with what I'm saying. Yeah.
So it depends on what,
what it might be in terms of that,
of the game.
You mentioned the design element
also works to another very
kind of sociologically grounded
way of seeing things. Um,
exclusivity.
So if content is delivered in
segments and you have to work for it,
it makes that particular segment
of the content seem exclusive,
that only a few people can get it.
That you have to go a certain distance.
You know,
it's,
you have to labor a little bit and
that creates all about a value to it.
So Games are designed,
those kinds of systems, um,
you'll see people laboring effectively,
you know, they call it the grind.
People will grind and world of Warcraft
for a certain amount of hours, right?
So they can get a certain amount
of like upper denture item. Um,
but that's different I think.
I think where we saw the MLG,
where I studied MLG thing really kick
in was in things like in video games,
like call of duty or in
things as on trick shots.
KDS or choke to death ratios or
things like on gear that you used.
Oh, our Astros for example, um,
surrounds on headsets because the Mlg
people use it. Everybody wanted to use it.
Right? So those, those
are kind of like product,
like straight up branding and product
placement and, um, endorsements.
So yeah, but it informs,
but not absolutely.
Okay. Last chance. All right.
Thank you.
[inaudible].